[Music]
okay we just saw one called
the Mustang which was a prison movie
about some convicts at the middle of the
Nevada desert in this special prison
where they were bringing in wild
mustangs and training them to sell them
back to like Border Patrol and the
police this was kind and they were kind
of an association with your Atlanta hero
of land manager it is an actual program
that exists is several western states
Wyoming California Nevada yeah and the
the prison looked like a real prison so
I'm assuming that that's I'm thinking
they probably shot it right looked very
everything yeah yeah it was kind of
rundown it might have been an abandoned
prison that's whatever but yeah and all
the guys in it look like real convicts
and stuff and it's kind of an
interesting story about a guy who he
he's getting into raising raising and
training horses and it's kind of like an
analogy for him trying to master himself
and his own in his own demons you know
[ __ ] goes down pretty much like it kind
of does a lot in prison movies you know
where certain guys get killed and
dilemmas kind of happen and they they
work themselves out I don't really don't
want to steal the movies Thunder because
I enjoyed the movie it was kind of like
kind of like an art house flicks I think
this was in Sundance Film Festival right
yeah and it was a yeah there was like
Studio canal like France and Belgium
stuff like that it's all Robert Redford
mostly the executive producers under
Stern was in and research was in it Oh
Bruce Dern then yeah well obviously yeah
so yeah a good job it is a very much it
is a very art house film but in some
ways I don't know like I really enjoyed
it a lot I mean you know just these the
cinematography is beautiful like all
these really big vistas of Nevada and
stuff like that much more and the guy
that plays the main character Roman
Coleman he's just he's so good because I
mean for a lot of the movie I can one of
the make I made points of the story is
that he's been in isolation at the
beginning of putting him back in general
population and he's not a not a people
person you know I didn't say much he
doesn't say much he's very stoic um but
he has like a lot of like really bad
like uh you know anger issues and he
gets he's very easily frustrated so when
he kind of gets tapped for this you know
horse training programs you know given
this particular course that's you know
it's really hard to break it's like
really kind of crazed and stuff like
that so good kind of bonds with the
animal and sort of like try in the least
like starts to get a hold of himself as
he like bonds with this animal who has a
lot in common
yes and some twists happened and a hit
it was kind of about well it ever themes
about self control and freedom and and
stuff like that also there was some
stuff that happened with some friends
that he had that he had in the program
which I don't want to spoil that but
real good score the acting was excellent
the storytelling was pretty good I
thought it was really good actually it
was kind of like prison movie meets
Western because these guys are gonna
have a cowboy quality and some of the
guys have kind of like an Indian quality
to them it feels like a westerner yeah
some way it's very much that that
yeah but yeah you know this like struck
me is kind of more like like a 70's
style like I guess the pacing is a lot
yes yeah like yeah let's go mostly I'd
recommend it yeah it's just yeah so
you're not talking about a fast pace
it's going to be or it's a character
study right more than anything right and
it's a very authentic feel to it yeah it
just depends on whether or not this is
something you'd be into yeah if you like
prison movies maybe westerns you you
know you could pry it yeah I think
probably I liked it a lot I kind of very
sure and I got like really into like you
know I was like really emotionally
invested in like yeah yeah it's pretty
you
all right it's Tom and Jen and we saw
two today first one we saw was one
called little and it's about this woman
who is a works she owns a software
company and she ends up getting cursed
by this little girl who have black girl
magic which is a had and turned her
small and then she tried to she had it's
kind of a long story she had to kind of
like relive her life in a certain way
and go back to school and kind of
correct the problems that she had
because she was a [ __ ] oh she's a [ __ ]
yeah and it was a good movie though it
was funny it was super cute it was kind
of like big you know the Tom Hanks yeah
movie is similar premise where he's like
the kind of opposite yeah it was
definitely a feel-good movie and you
know you know it's just it was just a
fun feel-good movie really more anything
else when you say yeah and I really
liked the relationship between between
her when she gets turned into a little
girl and her assistant who she had been
browbeating for the entire movie and
being of [ __ ] - and then you know but
when she turns into a kid she suddenly
like dependent on the assistant and
she's downstairs she later yeah though
the whole basic vote basically the whole
theme of the story was is that we kind
of know who we are when we're kids and
then life beats it out of you and then
you have to kinda like remember who you
were or we embrace who you were that was
party in us and don't be an [ __ ]
further than that you know good movie I
think was probably appropriate for
pretty much everyone in age wise and I
must say one thing is that that girl who
played the kid yeah she carried the
movie what was her name again
yeah yeah she could sing she could dance
and she could act and she can act like
an adult
she sold it because it like so much of
the movie like you know the character
was an adult for really only the
beginning in the end I mean yeah
she was a kid yeah you totally bought
that you totally bought that that was a
field in a kid's body her last name was
Martin yeah her last name was Martin
yeah she could sing act and meet you
probably see her in other movie she's
probably probably yes she was opposed to
be 13 in the movie yes I don't know
she's older than that she can't be that
much older because she does but she
doesn't look like a little kid yes yes
yes it's like she totally sold that yeah
that role and like I said her
interactions with the woman that played
her as the same yeah yeah but yeah
thumbs up you know that's good yeah
who's a cute movie you know it's nothing
deep or anything like that but it was it
was funny
okay second one we saw we saw Hellboy
yes yeah he'll boab is good yeah it was
good I saw the first towel boy know is
this this isn't quite a remake is it
yeah it is it's sort of is it's not
exactly the same it's exactly the same
story but it seemed very similar it's a
reboot yeah and it's his origin story
and then by the end of it I guess you
know again in a team are together yeah
yeah you know I've never read into comic
books only saw that of the first movie
yeah yeah and I would just say that it
was fun to watch had a lot more monsters
than the first one yeah a lot of good
action the edit was really fast it
unfolded pretty quickly I'd never
there's a lot in it I never got bored
really gory real glory like us yeah it
was good and it kind of had like a a
very light-hearted tone to it it's like
a light-hearted a monster movie with a
lot of Gorge
yeah black Lee comic you know cuz he's
very you know sardonic and he's always
kind of making these yeah quips and
stuff like that I had no complaints
about the movie I didn't either I
thought it was super fun it was like I
said I really I really liked like all
the the big action set pieces all the
monsters were really cool yeah and the
monsters were famous sometimes monsters
from legendary monsters you know I don't
want to spoil everybody who shows up but
there's a lot of stuff from mythology
one of my favorite a lot of witches I'm
gonna say that a lot of really cool
which action almost like one which kills
two other witches kind of like Suspiria
style crunches them up make remember
that and alright I'm gonna go ahead and
spoil it man Baba Yaga is in this [ __ ]
and the house and weren't we just saying
that was like yeah everybody everybody
[ __ ] Baba Yaga nat wolff this one dies
and yes the house was all movies really
should have Baba Yaga
I see [ __ ] James Bond baba Yaga James
Bond and Baba Yaga Superman abhava Yaga
baba Yaga
he was sucking it was a trick and if
it's a good baba Yaga - she really was I
did honestly for that I mean it was a
lot of like I liked a lot of the
monsters and stuff like that but she was
kind of the highlight
she's about she was like super girly
giant yeah it was just a monster packed
yeah you know some guy in it was
definitely a comic book movie it had a
comic book tone to it but I say you know
I enjoy it I like I like that kind of
stuff I'm sure there's gonna be a bunch
of fanboys that from the comic comics
they're gonna try to find something
wrong with the movie you know like to
usually do wanna come cry about it but
just for a casual fan you know and maybe
people that have seen the first movie I
thought this I thought this was better
than the first movie I did too although
I have to say that I prefer the first
guy that play what the hell yeah that
was I think this I think this dude did
good yeah guy like it's hard to fill
that dude shoes I'm just saying there
are some about that guy's voice and you
kind of swish in with that character but
you know he only did one movie yeah that
guy only did one if they do another
movie sequel there was a Hellboy to you
or there was a hard to fill that guy's
shoes that's what I mean but this dude
did a really good job visually that guy
did it needs acting was really good yeah
yeah I think I think he'll be a good
cowboy yeah because they're definitely
like set it up for more janitors yeah
alright that's good yeah
[Music]